الجيش الاسرائيلي مقتل ثلاثه جنود واصابه
اخر في حادث امنيه على الحدود مع مصر كما
اعلن عن تحيد مطلق النار
واوضح بيان الجيش الاسرائيلي انه ان من
وصفه بالمخرب هو شرطي مصري مشيرا الى ان
تحقيق في الحادث يتم بتعاون كامل ووثيق مع
الجيش المصري واضاف الجيش الاسرائيلي ان
قوته تواصل اعمال التمشيط في المنطقه
للتاكد من عدم وجود مخربين اخرين فيما نقل
اعلام اسرائيليه عن نتنياه قوله ان
الحادثه على الحدود مع مصر عابر ولن يؤثر
على التعاون المشترك
الجيش المصري من جهه اعلن عن مقتل عنصر
امن باطلاق نار اثناء مطاردته مهربين
مخدرات على الحدود مع اسرائيل وقال
المتحدث الرسمي باسم الجيش المصري ان عنصر
الامن اضطر لاختراق الحاجز الاسرائيلي
اثناء عمليه المطارده قبل ان يفارق الحياه
خلال تبادل لاطلاق النار
مصادر العربيه كشفت عن ان اتصالات المصريه
اسرائيليه قد تمت بهدف عقد اجتماعي امني
عاجل بشان اطلاق النار على الحدود بين
البلدين واضافت مصادر العربيه انه تم
تشكيل لجنه مصريه اسرائيليه بشان حاله
اطلاق النار على الحدود ومنع تكرار
من القاهره لمزيد من المتابع ينضم الي
مراسله العربيه تامر النصره تامر اهلا
وسهلا بك هل توضحت ملابسات هذا الحادث
وحقيقه ما جرى صباح فجر اليوم خصوصا
لناحيه الاسباب والخلفيات وليس لناحيه
النتائج يعني النتائج كل معروفه ما انتج
عنه هذا الحادث ولكن الاسباب والخلفيات
لانه البيانين الى حد ما متناقضين يعني
بيان الجيش المصري وبيان الجيش الاسرائيلي
بالطبع طالب وعاده مثل هذه الحوادث يتم
التعامل معها حاله بحاله بمعنى ان ظروف
بعض حوادث التهريب او غيرها من حوادث
اختراق الحدود تختلف عن ظروف اخرى مساله
مثلا عمليات الاتجار بالبشر تختلف في
طبيعتها عن تهريب المخدرات او تهريب
الاسلحه لناحيه ما يستخدم في كمعدات في في
هذه العمليات فالعبور او عبور مترجلين غير
عبور اشخاص بواسطه يعني سيارات او غيرها
من وسائل الانتقال فبالتالي عاده ما يتم
التعامل مع هذه الامور حاله بحاله مساله
البيان المصري الذي اوضح انه انها كانت
مطارده لاحد الافراد يعني هذا امر حدث
ويحدث عاده عندما تكون هناك امور تتعلق
بمراقبه الحدود من الطبيعي جدا ان يعني
تحدث هذه الامور مثلا الدخول داخل حدود
الدولتين وخاصه ان هناك تنسيق امني كبير
بينهما لهذه الناحيه هذا التنسيق ليس وليد
اليوم مثلا او غيره ولكن هو مستمر على
مدار فتره طويله ودخلت فيه القوات المسلحه
المصريه على الخط خاصه بعدما بدات تتواجد
في شبه جزيره سيناء منذ ان اطلقت مصر
عمليه القضاء على الارهاب في اعقاب ثوره
يونيو او يعني في اعقاب 2013 وتفاقم
العمليات الارهابيه سواء من سيناء او حتى
في الداخل المصريه فبالتالي كان لابد ان
يحدث تنسيق بين القوات المسلحه المصريه
والجيش الاسرائيلي لناحيه تواجد عناصر من
الجيش المصري في سيناء ليتضمن هذا طبعا
الشريف الحدودي يتضمن هذا عمليات تخص
الانفاق وبالتالي مساله التنسيق الامني
بينهما تتم على مستويات كبيره ايضا
المسائل المتعلقه بالربط الحدود متغيره
جدا وخاصه اتباع المهربين لاساليب مختلفه
كل مره بطبيعه الحال بعد ان يتم اكتشاف
ما زاد من الغموض او ما زاد الامور غموضا
اكثر انه في متحدث باسم الجيش الاسرائيلي
صباح اليوم قال انه الحادث مدبر ومخطط له
لا الجيش المصري يقول لا انه هذا حادث
يتعلق بعمليات مطارده مهربين مخدرات وهنا
هنا السؤال يعني
من يستطيع يعني الان تحديد ملابسات ما جرى
اسباب ما جرى لانه يعني شاسع بين ان يقال
الحادث مدبر ومخطط له وبين انه يكون حادث
عرضي يعني جرم يتعلق بمهربين مخدرات
هذا طبعا سيتضح اذا نتج عن الاجتماع
الامني التنسيقي بين الجانبين اي اصدارات
للاعلام يعني تعلم تماما ان مثلا الجيش
الدفاع الاسرائيلي كما يطلق عليه من
الممكن ان يكون يعتبر هذا النوع يعني
اختراق كبير له او تراخي كبير من الجانب
الحدودي له فيطلق البيان الذي يناسب داخل
الاسرائيلي وعلى الجانب المصري مثلا جاءنا
البيان الذي صدر عن المتحدث الرسمي للقوات
المسلحه المصريه والذي عاده ما تكون
بيانات واضحه وصريحه جدا عن ما يحدث في
هذه الحاله مثل هذا الامر لن يتضح الا اذا
اسفر الاجتماع بين الجانبين على مزيد من
الاجراءات الامنيه او اعلن بالتفصيل عن
ماهيه ما حدث وكيفيه حدوثه من الواضح مثلا
في الجانب المصري او في البيان المصري
عفوا اذا قرات اخر سطر فهو تقدم بالتعازي
اسر الضحايا والترمينيات بالشفاء
للمصابين يعني هذا الامر في نوع من يعني
الشعور بالاسى ومحاوله
المشاطره في الاحزان مع الجانب الذي سقط
منه ضحايا وعلى الجانب الاخر هناك ايضا
سقوط
الفرد الامن المصريه الذي كان منوط به هذه
العمليه فمساله
ظبط الحدود هي مساله معقده جدا لا تكون
فيها الامور تتعلق بخطوط مستقيمه والتحرك
فيها عاده ما ينتج عنه الدخول بين الحدود
يعني اتحدث هنا مثلا عن التنسيق الذي يحدث
ما بين القوات المصريه والقوات الليبيه
غربا ما بين القوات المصريه والقوات
السودانيه جنوبا فهذا هذه امور تعتاد
عليها القوات التي تقف على جانبي شريط
حدودي بين اي دولتين من القاهره مراسل
العربيه من نصره شكرا جزيلا لك تامر على
كل هذه المتابعه من معبر نيتسانا مراست
العربيه لانك الغاصي تتابع الاحداث اولا
باول وملابسات هذا الحادث الان اهلا وسهلا
بك كيف هو المشهد من عندك على المعبر وعلى
جانبي الحدود وهل هنالك روايه اسرائيليه
واضحه متكامله لمجاره
اهلا بك فعليا نحن نتواجد بالقرب من
الحدود المصريه على هذا المعبر اللي هو
فعليا معبر يعني قامت السلطات الاسرائيليه
باغلاقه يعني كما ترى من خلفه هو معبر
مغلق حتى الان والمنطقه التي تم بها اطلاق
النار او تبادل لاطلاق النار اعلنتها
اسرائيل بانها منطقه عسكريه مغلقه قامت
بتوجيه عدد من القوات والتعزيزات الامنيه
والعسكريه التي توجهت منذ ساعات الى منطقه
تبادل النار ايضا في طريقنا الى هذه
المنطقه كان هناك اغلاق لبعض
الطرق قامت القوات الاسرائيليه بنصب حواجز
تفتيش لبعض المركبات اين نتحدث عن حاله
تاهب وحاله ترقب كبيره في هذه المنطقه
تحديدا واخر بيان كان صادر من قبل الشرطه
الاسرائيليه الناطق العسكري قال بان ما
زالت تواصل قوات الجيش الاسرائيليه اعمال
التمشيط في المنطقه ولتاكيد عدم وجود اي
مسلحين اخرين يتواجدون في المنطقه هل يرى
الجانب الاسرائيلي لانا ان الحادث مدبر
وله خلفيات غير خلفيات جرميه تتعلق بموضوع
تهريب المخدرات ام لا يعني اقتنع الجانب
الاسرائيلي بالروايه المصريه والبيان
المصري انه هذا الحادث لا خلفيات لا
سياسيه ولا غير سياسيه ولا ايديولوجيه له
يعني حتى الان لا يوجد هناك بيان رسمي
يقوم بالتعليق على البيان الاخير الصادر
من القوات المصريه التي تقول بان الجندي
المصري الذي تتهمه اسرائيل بقتل الثلاثه
جنود فعليا هو يعني كان يلاحق حسب الروايه
المصريه كان يلاحق مهربين حاولوا تهريب
المخدرات والقوات الاسرائيليه قامت بقتله
فعليا ولكن يعني البيان الاسرائيلي يؤكد
يعني ما زال على روايته التي تقول بان
الجندي المصري قد اجتاز الحدود واطلق
النار على الجنود الاسرائيليين ويعني
مازال هناك فعليا بحث ومحاوله لتفسير هذا
الحدث ما هي اسباب هذه العمليه هل فعليا
هي عمليه يعني تقوم بسبب او هدف ما من قبل
هذا الجندي ام هناك اتهامات اسرائيليه
يعني يعني لا يزال المشهد واضح ولكن
الاتهامات الاسرائيليه ما زالت موجوده لها
تغيير في البيان الاسرائيلي الناطق
العسكري باسم الجيش الاسرائيلي يقول بان
منفذ هذه العمليه هو جندي ينتمي للجيش
المصري وكان مرتدي للزيج للجيش المصري هذه
فعليا هذا ما حسب البيان الذي صدر منذ
ساعتين طيب لنا هل من معلومات كم ستستمر
عمليه اغلاق المعابر بين مصر واسرائيل
خصوصا معبر يعني
شكرا جزيلا لك الان على كل هذه المتابعه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات